this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much maria thanks for the
invitation and and for the kind
introduction it
sort of makes me feel aging um
so so yes it's it's a pleasure to talk
to people and i'll talk to
some more people uh after my my seminar
um i'm just sorry that i can't be there
physically because you know we were we
were
ruining the fact that over the last year
we haven't been able to chat
and and that's where a lot of science
sort of chewing over and discussion
goes on but um hopefully you can chew
through what i'm going to tell you today
and
and i welcome any feedback critical
feedback or whatever
um so um i've entitled my talk studying
in our immunity networks across the
plant species because we've been
interested um
for quite a long time in in how plants
regulate
their immune innate immune responses to
host adapted
uh pathogens and for the most part we've
been working in arabidopsis for obvious
reasons as a genetic and also
molecular uh and phenotypic model but
more recently
um we've been asking the question as to
whether the
defense networks that we and others have
defined in in arabidopsis
to what extent those defense properties
hold for
other plant other unrelated plant
species
so for example solanaceae and then even
extending to the monocot
plant species that have different immune
receptor repertoires
and so i'm going to touch a little bit
on that that that later
point but i'm going to tell you mostly
about um
sort of work that we've done in the last
couple of years to try and unpick
nlr downstream signaling so
activation to to signaling so i want to
share with you
some of that some of the results there
so just to set the stage um and this is
really enshrined now in our models of of
uh innate immunity both in plants but
also in in mammalian systems to some
extent is that you have
two receptor barriers the first is at
the surface the cell surface
these are called pattern recognition
receptors and they
recognize various pathogen associated
or endogenous molecules and that gives
rise to
a resistance response that we call
pattern-triggered immunity or pti
there's loads of acronyms in immunity
i'm sorry for that
um and then those pathogens that have
adapted to a particular host genotype
they uh produce effector molecules
uh that are delivered in various ways
into the host cell
and those batteries of effectors enable
the the
microbe to to overcome this this
first defense layer the pr defense layer
and to
to gain traction so to infect and cause
disease
but those effectors then um have
driven the selection of this second
barrier the nucleotide binding leucine
rich repeat receptor
immunity layer and that's called
effector-triggered immunity because
those nlrs
are acutely sensitive to specific
effector molecules or
what effector molecules do to endogenous
host components
and that then triggers this
effector-triggered immune response
and in recent years there's been a lot
learnt
uh about how effectors trigger nlrs and
i think we're beginning to understand
how nls then signal um downstream
and i should mention that traditionally
these two
immunity layers have been considered as
rather separate entities but there's
some recent data
not from ourselves but from other groups
if you're interested which tends to
suggest there is much more crosstalk
between the pr and the nlr um barriers
than than was previously
um thought so
um so one of the fascinating things
about
nlrs is that the same
uh protein modules or a similar sort of
architectural
logic applies across animals and
and plants and this is this is shown
very nicely for example nlrs that
you find in humans and and groups of
nlrs that you find
for example in in arabidopsis but that
applies also to
other plant
genomes and the common principle is
essentially that they have these
central um nucleotide binding
oligomerization domains
they have sensor domains that are often
repeat domains and you can see
loose and rich repeats occur quite
frequently
that lend themselves for specific record
recognition and variation in recognition
of
of uh triggering molecules and then they
all have these sensor domains
at the end terminus so various uh
different domains
often involved in homotypic interactions
so those
domains then are come together to form a
form a signaling module and one of the
fascinating things about plants is that
of course
unlike mammals they have expanded
the number and diversified their nlr
repertoires
much more greatly and that's probably
driven by this acute
pathogen effector selection because they
rely on innate immunity
for the resistance um i
should then highlight here there are two
main classes
of sensor nlr in plants
so across course plants the one
subclass has a tall interleukin-1
receptor-like domain
so that's a domain that's also found in
in animal systems
and those are called tear nlrs or tnls
for short
and there are some examples here in
arabidopsis that will recur in my talk
because
uh some we've done some work on um
then there's another group of center lr
that instead has a
coil coil domain or a coil coil-like
domain
and and there are some very good
examples of those in arabic and other
plants for example are the rpm1 and
argus to
well well-studied cnls so those are two
major subclasses of of
sensor nlr in terms of sensing effector
changes um and i should also highlight
because this will come later in my talk
a subclass of nlrs that are not sensor
nlrs but
and they have a somewhat variant uh
domain that we call the ccr or the helo
domain because it resembles
helo domains that are found across
organisms it's a very interesting um
cc-like domain um and in plants these
divide again into
two subgroups that are called adr ones
and nrg ones
and i will return to those so so um
keep those in mind
and in plants and animals these
nlrs all work by the same principle
they're very tightly controlled
molecular switches
so they upon some sort of perturbation
it's an effector or it's some
post-modified molecule or it can be a
microbial pattern that then triggers a
conformational change
usually by the starting at the
leucine-rich repeat domain
conformational change that involves
usually um
exchange nucleotide exchange so adp for
atp exchange
and then that gives rise to an activated
molecule and that then sets in in train
the downstream responses and of course
because these are activating immune
responses in both systems so
in mammals and implants they have to be
very very tightly controlled and there
are various
um there are multiple checks
essentially at the transcriptional and
the post-transcriptional level to make
sure that
in it that most of these nrrr's are kept
in a in a in a controlled
[Music]
condition so that it maintains uh
homeostasis
but there are in both systems examples
very very nice examples of where that
homeostasis
is is lost and there's misregulation of
nlr's
um for example here there are a number
of snips found in
in um that underlie um human autoimmune
diseases
and these are due to a loosening of the
leucine rich repeats
which are normally tightly bound to the
nucleotide binding
um oligomerization data domain and that
then leads to a leaky
autoimmunity which is which could be
very damaging by the same criterion
there's a there are a number of
autoimmune plants that have been
identified
many of them are due to misregulation of
the of the nlrs
and there's this famous one that was
identified by my colleague chin lee
in the ubc in vancouver and that and you
can see the fitness penalty
uh that that's caused by a misregulation
of this um
in this case it's a tear domain um nlr
and that's due to a single amino acid
exchange in the
nucleotide binding domain so so there is
a
it's important to keep these as very um
tightly controlled
um regulated systems
so um for a long time we didn't
understand what constituted a sort of
active
nlr neither in the mammalian field nor
in the plant field
and then there was a breakthrough in
about 2017 and this is exemplified by
this paper
um from the russell vance that showed
the cryonium structure of a
what's called an inflammasome oligomeric
oligomer complex that you can see here
and essentially that is seeded by one
sensor nlr that recognizes a pump
and that then becomes activated and then
causes an oligomerization of the helper
nlr which is not
four so knight knight five is the sensor
not for is the
the helper you could say the ancillary
nlr and that creates this
cartwheel structure then that then acts
as a
scaffold for concentrating um
for example caspases and adapter
proteins that then
allow a concentrated enzymatic mechanism
which then
helps to process pro-inflammatory
molecules so that's really quite well
worked out now and then later so 2019
and then in 2000 the end of 2020
the cryo-em structures of the two
different types of
of sensor nlr the coil coil
sensor nlr uh were resolved
and you can see this this absolutely
beautiful
uh structure of an activated um
coil coil domain so c l sar1 this is an
arabidopsis and a
c l that recognizes a bacterial
effector actually indirectly and that
effector then modifies a
a protein that's bound to the analog and
then that creates this this
oligomer structure and then
um uh in the end of 2020 and we were
involved with gigi chai but i must give
credit to judy shy whose team
solve the cryon structure of
rpp1 this is a well-known arabidopsis
tier nlr and at the same time the group
of
um ava nogales and and brian stascovitz
solved the structure of of um rock one
which is a tobacco um
uh tier nlr and i'm showing you the rpp1
um activated uh complex in this case
it's not a pentamer it's a tetramer but
you can see the same principle in these
these um nlrs both the cc and the at the
tier domain analyst
is that what the oligomerization does is
it assembles in an ordered way those
n-terminal domains so here's the
cc domains and here it's an assemblage
of the tier domains
and we discovered that this disassembly
for the tier domains of course is a very
um structured one and very important
for a as as maria said of a an enzymatic
activity um
so so that was a certainly an insight to
the
activation mechanism um i should mention
that in the
so the structure also um
showed um a domain in the c
terminus of of the um uh tier nlr's that
we didn't know from the sequence so the
primary sequence so it only
became it only emerged with the
structure and then we did some hmm
analysis and found that this c terminal
domain that we call the cjid
for a c terminal jelly roll ig
like domain that's a mouthful um
um and and that seems to be present so
by hmn
present in a number not all but many um
tnls
and what we found through a structure
function analysis is that
it helps solidify or
it was sort of the discriminate i think
the specific interaction between the
effector
and the leucine rich repeat so this is
the effector molecule in this case atr1
and this this very very c-terminal end
of the the tier nlr
helps to to solidify and sort of firm up
that that specific interaction
so that was something that was new that
came out of that uh analysis
so if we go to a comparative between the
um zarwan cnl um
activated oligomer and the
tnls um the work of gigi chai
showed really quite compelling evidence
that it's
it's it's a source of the oligomer the
activated form
binds to the plasma membrane where it
can form
a possible pore or channel um
and so that's that's formed by these
very end terminal helices
in that that are the that that poke into
the membrane
in psalm one um there was a
a very um important breakthrough through
uh two papers that came came out in 2019
that showed that by contrast the tier
domains of tnls
um as well as truncated forms of of tear
domain
containing proteins have an enzymatic
activity
and that depends on a an amino acid so a
key catalytic
residue and a similar environment found
for a molecule
that that works in neuronal cell death
and that was was well characterized that
has this tear module
so there was this similar amino acid
environment and and through
amino acid exchanges then this was
discovered to be
a catalytic active site for these tear
domains in implants
and what was discovered is that a
possible substrate is
nad and then there were some possible
candidate molecules that were products
of this
activity and the activity required a
homodymerization
home or a heterodymerization of the tier
domains
and also of course the catalytic residue
and so
this leads us to proposing the field
that that maybe
these products that are generated by
this tier
activity um are crucial signal
intermediates to the downstream signal
and if we go into then the structure
again in more detail of the
assembled tier domains in the
the uh tetrameric oligomer so this is
the
active activated form that has active
nada's activity you can see
that there are two symmetrical
homodimers
uh that are associating through known
homodymerization
surfaces but what's crucial is that the
oligomerization causes a shift
in the the sort of a switch in those
those orientations such that those two
homodimers become
asymmetrically arranged and that's shown
here so this is the asymmetry uh
two asymmetric pairs and it's that
asymmetry
that causes that creates this active
site and a hollow enzyme
so the nada's active site so there's
this oligomerization and this then this
twist
that creates a a a an arrangement for a
very efficient catalytic activity so i
think what the nlr
is doing or at least what these domains
are doing is is
creating a very uh highly kinetic
efficient active enzyme surface that can
work at low concentrations
and that was something that gigi showed
very nicely in the paper
so we've been studying for a number of
years together with the honda land
that's in
in toulouse an arabidopsis tier
nlr pair that's called rs1 and rps4 and
it's it
it's really a well-known
tnl pair that recognizes a number of
different
pathogens and it's best known for its a
recognition of a bacteria so a
pseudomonas syringe
secreted effectively is for um
and and that's that's produced by this
this leaf infecting pathogen
um but it similarly recognizes pop p2
which is a
acetyl transferase that's produced by
this root infecting pathogen called
rastonia
and we know that those effectors are
intersected
by this nlr pair this tier nr pair
um through a decoy domain
that's at the c terminus of rs1 and that
decoy domain resembles a worky
dna binding site of of working
transcription factors this is a
a large family of plant-specific
transcription factors that orchestrate
biotic and abiotic stress responses and
so
that intersection through the binding or
in this case a popular
transacetylation of the working domain
dislodges
the heterodimer from its position
at the the dna and that's sufficient to
activate
um the the the tier nr response
and it's interesting that rps4 has that
cjid domain um
in in it's uh no sorry i beg your pardon
um forget what i say it doesn't
um uh rps4 has
in its um tier domain the catalytic
residue that shows that it's a
active enzyme whereas rs1 does not
um so that fits with perhaps
in this activated heterodimer that um
and it's thought that it stays as a head
driver there must be a reorientation of
the tier domains of rps4
such that it creates that then that
hollow enzyme and that that's something
that's really exciting
to perhaps resolve for the for the nlr
pair
so so we've talked about activation um
of
llr's in particular tnl's and i've i've
mentioned also the cnl
activation mechanism and the initial
activation seems to be
somewhat different so what about the
next um
steps in the the signaling cascade what
we knew
um and this was all identified by
genetic analysis
in in arabidopsis many years ago that
one crucial early component of
tnl signaling so that's downstream of
the effector-activated tnls as well as
the auto-activated tnls
is this lipase-like nucleocytoplasmic
protein called eds-1
and we knew from earlier studies that
es1 associates with a number of tnls in
nuclei
so it seems to be at least closely
associated with some tnls
we never really discovered what the
relevance of that association is but it
suggests that it's really proximal and
that would fit with the fact that it's
required for
all of the outputs that can be measured
that are triggered by
itns and um
it's the founder member of a small class
of
lipase-like proteins the two other
members of which are pad 4
and and sag 101 and these occur in seed
plants so they're not
found in earlier land plant lineages so
they've evolved
in seed plants to somehow act as these
signaling components for
for um tnl receptors and
we know that eds1 forms mutually
exclusive
heterodimers with its two uh sequence
related partners pad 4 and sac
and a lot of early work we did in in
relation to the function of eds one with
pad four
and we know that this heterodimer is
is important for conferring what's
described rather sort of enigmatically
as a basal immunity
branch and that's
that's a branch that is distinctive
and contributes to the tnl immune
response
and i don't have time to go into it now
but i'm very happy to
discuss what i think basal immunity is
in this this context but just for the
time being it's it's
it's it's this heterodimer is very
important for the transcriptional
defense reprogramming that's
triggered by tnls and what it does
is it prioritizes in arabidopsis at
least it prioritizes
the salicylic acid defense pathway and
salicylic acid is a very important
biotic stress
defense molecule and it does this by
counteracting the activities of ja and
and there's a bacterial mimic of ja
which is an effector molecule
called coronating so so it allows this
this boosting of the sa defenses and
and and other defenses so that's one out
very important output of this this this
this heterodimer the eds one platform
heterodimer
so if we look at the structure
of the uh two heterodimers of uh there's
a crystal structure of of eds one side
101 and then
there was a structural model made of es1
platform
you can see why these complexes are
mutually exclusive because eds-1 has a
similar surface it forms and it this is
dominated by a
hydrophobic um helix that fits into
quite similar pockets of the two
partners of sac 101 and pad 4
you can see that in more detail here
and that that that interaction
so from the analysis that we've done by
structure guided mutant analysis
shows that that's important for bringing
the two molecules together
and bringing together this very
um god says my internet connection is
unstable i hope that
doesn't crash and bringing together
what we now know is the um action end of
the the molecule which is these these
two um what we call ep domains so these
are alpha helical coil domains and they
need to be brought together
to form a signaling active um molecule
in both cases and i've
i've put here catalytic pocket because
these lipase domains
are um certainly an eds one pad four
really
absolutely classical alpha beta
hydrolase domains
but and they have a they have a
conserved catalytic residues but when we
knock those residues out then we don't
we don't disable the immunity sitting at
all so our current thinking that is that
this is acting as a non-catalytic
scaffold in the immune response that as
i say brings together these these two
molecules and the the
important c terminal uh domains
and part of the evidence that showed
that those the cedar
terminal domains the heterodimer are
really important is that they
create a a cavity a very prominent
cavity
and around that cavity are some
conserved amino acids that we that we
exchanged
uh for example in eds one and we've now
done it in pad four and also actually
sag 101
um i have to say saguana on surface is
somewhat different and that's probably
uh quite relevant and when we when we
knock out or when we we exchange those
residues
they don't interfere with the
heterodymerization but they interfere
very strongly with the signaling
capability of the heterodyne and i
emphasize that because there are some
reports
of eds one itself interacting with a
number of
transcription factors and there was a
recent report of
of mpr1 interacting with es1 that's
super interesting but i think it also
has to be understood in the
in the context of the fact that eds1
without its partner doesn't do anything
so we can produce buckets of eds-1 if it
doesn't have either one of its direct
partners pad 4 or sag-101
we don't get any signaling so my feeling
is that we really have to understand the
heterodimer
and that that's the that's the active
form whereas eds1
is more of the the ground state which
could still of course be
relevant um and there was one very
interesting
exchange that uh that a postdoc deepak
vander i identified which was
which was an amino acid exchange of one
of these conserved arginines in the eds
one
um ep domain that borders this this this
cavity
and that created unusually a a weak
allele so weakly functional
allele of edius one most of them weren't
sort of a full loss of functionalities
and it didn't interrupt the the
heterodimerization it didn't
interfere with the nuclear cytoplasmic
localization of the the um of the
heterodimer
but what it does is it doesn't
efficiently
efficiently transcriptionally reprogram
the cells
in response so this is this this is the
response to pst abs
rps4 that's recognized by rs1 rps4 this
is a system that we
look at the dynamics of the
transcriptional reprogramming and the
resistance
and so for here you can see in this pca
plot so these are
differentially expressed genes at eight
hours 24 hours
between this weak allele of eds-1
versus the null mutant or versus the
wild-type
transformed line and at eight hours the
weak alia looks very like in terms of
differentially expressed genes very like
the the eds one now
but by 24 hours it's pretty much caught
up with the
wild type response but that catch up
is insufficient for it to confer
resistance
and by gradually doing a sort of more
fine-graded analysis of the critical
time window that's required
for this to efficiently rapidly
a reprogramming transcription it's
between
four and eight hours for this particular
immune response so that tells us that
there's this critical window
in which that immune transcriptional
response has to happen
and if it doesn't happen at that point
then it's then it's essentially game
over in terms of
the pathogen um overcoming um resistance
and that's i important because we base
some of our
later analysis on on on capturing what's
going on in that
in that time window
so i want to now tell you about a whole
body of data and i've just put it
into one model here um that was produced
um by ourselves and also many other
groups so jonathan jones's group
chinle that there was a sort of a surge
of papers
which was analyzing um the
the tnl and in fact in some cases the c
l reliance on these two
um heterodimers eds1 pad 4 and eds1 sag
101
and as well as the requirement
of tier nlrs for
um these two different classes of helper
nlr or rnl
so this is the helper and laws that i
mentioned before that fall into these
two classes of the adr ones
and the nrg ones and in arabidopsis
there are three
parallels of adrs and uh also three nrgs
um except one uh chinese group has shown
is probably a non-functional
truncated form of energy and the upshot
of all of that analysis that i can say
you know relatively in a short way
is that different tnls rely to
different extents on these two
downstream pathways and we showed
that those two pathways are genetically
non-interchangeable
so you can't cross use various
components these are really
um hardwired for eds one pad four
to work with ones and eds-1
sag-101 to work genetically with nrg
ones and in analyzing the rs1 rps4
response in terms of the different
outputs so the resistance to pathogen
as well as a ability to trigger host
cell death which is an important
component of the egi response we found
that the eds1 pad 4 and i've explained
before this is this is really
transcriptionally
very active and it's very very important
for the resistance and many tnls
use this preferentially for the
resistance response and that tends to
mask this other
pathway the eds-1 side 101 which
at least has a more efficient capacity
to trigger the host cell death
so it looks as if qualitatively these
are not identical
outputs and it would be very interesting
at some point to discuss about you know
what
is the decision making between this
branch or this branch
so that's all in arabidopsis so the
arabidopsis tnls can go this way
this whale they can use a bit of the the
the two branches
um in tobacco so in benthamian where we
can reconstitute
resistance responses so for example the
tnr response confirmed by
rock one that recognizes a bacterial
effect as op-q
and this has been very well sort of
worked out as a system to look at tnl
responses in
in as well as if you express
say an uh arabidopsis tnl that will also
work in the endpentamiana system
that relies entirely on this branch
the eds-1 sag-101 nrg1 branch
um and this i think that's interesting
in that it doesn't utilize in the tnl
immune response this branch adr1 eds one
pad four
even though there are conserved and
functional orthologs of these components
uh
in the tobacco system so bear that in
mind for
what i'm going to say later so
um dimitri so so we have this genetic
um evidence of these two
branches or nodes that are operating
downstream
of of of tnl um activation
um and dimitri lapar uh
a really talented postdoc in the lab
together with vira kovacova at the
university of cologne
did a phylogenetic analysis of the eds-1
family across seed plants
so they identified orthologs in about 45
different
uh species spanning the the angiosperms
and the gymnosperms where
we knew that these these genes occurred
and then analyze the the the different
lineages and um we found that whereas
eds1 and path4
and the adr1s are occur
across the angiosperms and the
gymnosperms so they're really widely
distributed
sag wanna ones and the nrg ones
um have a limited occurrence and they've
been lost
selectively from a number of angiosperm
of a number of dicot lineages and from
monocot lineages
and this fitted with the occurrence of
tnl receptors and that was shown
really very elegantly by blake myers
group and then later by by
a number of other groups so the
occurrence of tnl's is
limited and this strong co-occurrence
signature between tnl's the sag-101s and
nrg1
suggested to us that there might be a
co-function
so a coevol function uh in this
particular node
and that was also suggested that perhaps
these you know because they're curved
they they work molecularly together
and i just want to show you one piece of
data from a paper that's
already published so you can go into it
if if you're interested
but i think it illustrates um how these
modules
have to work and that is that they
that it's only components from the same
clade
within this module that seem to work
together if you use
cross-clade combinations they don't
operate
so here this is the cell death response
measure by iron leakage
quantitative cell death in the tobacco
system in which we've
reconstituted a tobacco plant in which
we've crispered all of the eds one
family so this is called mbe pss
so we've got rid of all of the
endogenous eds-1
components and then we've
co-expressed various uh arabidopsis
components to see whether we can
reconstitute the tnl immune response
and this is rock one recognizing zot q
so you can see in the wild type
enventhemiana
if you deliver us up q you get this very
nice uh cell vs response so that's our
sort of positive control
um and it's that's clearly xoxo
dependent um
then if we start adding in various
components so here we've got solenacious
eds1 with a sag-101 form that we knew
was
was functional that also that also
creates a
cell death response so absorb q
dependent cell death response
and then we started adding in various
components and so eds1
with pad 4 sag 101 and it was only when
we added
eds1 arabidopsis eds1 with arabidopsis
sag 101
and arabidopsis nrg1 it could be either
of the nrg1 functional isoforms that we
get that reconstituted cell there
and that was very striking because it
suggested to us that really this is this
is you need that
molecular compatibility that's not
provided
between clades for that signaling system
to to operate and
in this system the pad four whether it
was expressed with eds one together with
adr ones didn't work
so it wasn't that we were using the
wrong combination so
so so that that emphasizes that in in
tobacco you're really
feeding tnl resistance through this um
eds this
uh sag 101 nrg1 um
clade branch so
again so that just i just show it here
that this this i think it provides some
good evidence that we have this
co-functions of of the tnls with eds one
second one nrg ones
um and that that represents a a
resistance cell their signaling module
and i just wanted to reiterate
that i think it's it's super interesting
that
the c l's don't seem to require these
components for resistance and cell death
and it's thought that maybe the c
l through this poor forming activity
that i showed fazal one
maybe that's a common uh way in which
they can
trigger the immune response and cell
death whereas
the tnls require these additional
components to fulfill
the the immune signaling so they're so
they're working in in rather
different ways to to achieve the same
response and so
okay oh gosh sorry i'm going a bit over
time
i'm gonna so so we did some analyses
where we um did we did mass spec
analysis
where we used various components whether
it's eds1
sag 101 or pad 4 in arabidopsis and
asked what we pulled down
at an early time point so this four to
eight hour time frame where we knew
at least there should be some sort of
activity that that is important
and we found initially that the nrgs and
this is in nuclear extracts
interesting nrgs interact with eds one
so this was the bait in this case and
this this is a quantitative
proteomic uh peptide analysis so so they
were coming down with with eds one
saguaro one and pad four also
obviously highly enriched and then
in reciprocal analysis we we used
instead of eds1 these are all native
express
tagged versions complementing the the
mutants
we we use a comparison of sag 101 yfp
tag with pad 4 yfp tagged
both in a background where the other
branch would not interfere
with with the complementing protein
and these showed and this was done at
six hours so it sort of going a little
bit more to
an earlier time point and in this case
we were triggering with pfo which
delivers avr
is four very cleanly and the mass spec
analysis showed
that with sag 101 we enriched the nrgs
as well as of course eds one
whereas with pad four we enriched
more the adrs that did not come down
with the sac-101 so it
looks as if this genetic discrimination
of these pathways is borne out also by
some sort of molecular
discrimination so there seem to be these
induced associated complexes of
these eds1 family heterodimers with with
different um helper nlrs and then a
crucial experiment that
joanne fiehan did and this is in the
collaboration with jonathan jones
johannes jonathan's lab
and this is one one where she used a
complementing
so this is in a different background a
complementing nrg1
tagged transgenic line
and she used that then to ip
um extracts from
extracts that have been triggered by pfo
alone
so this would trigger a pti response
essentially
or pfo expressing avrps4 will trigger a
tnl
eti response and what she should what
she found in that ip
so when she i peed nrg1
with flag is that it's only in the eti
triggered response that she is able to
pull down eds1
and then we looked at the mass spec data
here and
that was associated also with sac 101
not
with pad 4 with adr1 so this says to us
that there and this is at a time frame
before
really it's just at the cusp of the
transcriptional reprogramming
so this says to us that an eti
signal a trigger is required for
this uh some sort of induced association
between eds-1 and sag-101 and
and nrg1 and i think that's
that's uh suggested that the pti alone
is not sufficient
um and i'm going to just um go
cut now to to just a final slide
in which we've used the
tobacco system so a slight tweak on the
tobacco reconstitution system that i
showed you before where we could follow
the timing
of the tnl activated uh uh
signaling a bit more precisely and we
found there so this is in the zop q
triggered system so this
is this is this is the rock one
resistance response
uh that even though we co-express
earlier all of these components
you need again the tnl trigger
to observe an association between
um nrg1 and eds1 seg101 and that that
comes in this case
about 12 hours and that does not occur
when we
when we use pfo alone so both in the
arabidopsis system
and in the tobacco system it looks as if
we have this this eti
induced association i think that's
important for the resistance response
and then we made a number of mutants in
the eds-1 heterodimer
as well as in a modeled form of nrg1
that was modeled on the oligomer of
tsar1 and all of these mutations that we
made
knock out the signaling but only a
portion of them knock out the
interaction between
eds1 psyc101 and nrg1 and those are this
p loop defect so this doesn't allow the
energy one two
we think probably oligomerize activate
um but not these n terminal residues
that would resemble the residues that
are important for
something that could resemble a poor sr1
so those do not interfere with
interaction between nrg1
and eds-1 sac-101 but the ep domain
residues that are crucial for signaling
also interfere with that
and so from that we come to some sort of
scheme or model where
we have this activated tnl it's
producing an nada's activity we think
it's
it's giving rise to some signal
intermediate that that could bind
either to eds one side 101 or to nrg1 or
both
we need the activated form of nrg1 as
well as the
competent ep domain of eds one side 101
for there to be a eti induced
association
and we would argue that that association
is likely to be important
an important step for the activation of
the defense response
i think we gradually sort of getting
more more sort of unpicking um the the
requirements for the response
so i'll stop now because i know i'm over
time
um and i'll miss i'll i won't talk about
this
so i'd like to thank um members of my
group fantastic
uh group of of people particularly uh
dimitri
um tinhua who contributed to the work
that i'm talking about also yoram
uh and patrick and my wonderful
wonderful technician jacqueline
and all of our collaborators um uh cast
and leaf in the university of cologne
law i've mentioned the work here
gigi chai in cologne
um also um hightower q
and i mentioned some analysis that we've
done with joanna and
um uh jonathan so thanks very much and
i'm very happy to take some questions if
we have time
thank you jane that's very good thanks
this is
thanks for a great talk what factor do
you think is important in choosing
between the two paths
the type of pathogen or the effector or
something else
that's a great question um we don't know
what you always say it's a great
question when you don't know we don't
know
the answer i have an idea and i think
that it might be the strength of the egi
signal so if for example
the tnl is so in those tissue in those
cells in which the tnl is being directly
activated
um i think that then that should should
signal through the eds while sagging on
nrg1
branch whereas we know and this goes
down to this basal
immunity so so i see the eds 1.4 adr one
branch is the basal immunity up front
and i suspect and and if you look at the
data and we talked about this in an
annual review if you're interested
at least an argument so various pieces
of data which suggests that the
basal immunity blunt is acting as a con
as a reinforcer
in cells around that that immediate
um effect triggered focus
so i i think they're probably working to
different extent so if you have a weaker
tnl response you might then
tune it into the eds one pad four basal
response because you have a strong one
then you then you go into
to um uh the other branch so that's
that's my thinking but
you know we might well
um and i think lilian has her hand up
for one
i do um thank you
i'm always a big
fan of choosing a model and
discovering everything one can about
pathways and so on
um unfair question how do we
translate this to the field and
control disease in the field
yeah yeah so that's that it's
actually i'm going to be
unfair as well i think the most
power we have in terms of um
engineering resistance and translating
it to the field
i don't think it's necessarily in the
signaling components but i think it's in
the nlrs themselves
and there's just some super work going
on about in
in terms of designing integrated domains
in such a way that you can broaden the
the recognition space without
auto triggering you know upsetting the
the balance of the the the
um defense homeostate so i
my feeling is if you're doing
translational science and and now's
a time if ever there were the
opportunity
um the the the the the understanding the
lnrs
and the the different types of nlrs and
how you have complementary sets of nlrs
is the best way to go for for
engineering
um robust resistance
um i from a
one thing i think was very surprising at
least to me
from from our analysis was that we
didn't expect there to be such
selectivity in the signaling components
down
downstream so so that that was a
surprise to me that so
if you wanted to mobilize that cassette
into another unrelated plant you'd have
to
take all of the co-evolved components
with you
and that's what that's what it tells us
um
and we're doing some analysis in in rice
where we're crispering a number of these
components and that's to really be able
to understand well what are the basic
because rice doesn't have tnls so that's
a system in which we can
i think unpick um um
how these circuits work in a in a in a
crop
plant so that doesn't answer your
question but but it gives my preference
as to where i think the field should be
going for
thank you so much
um there's a question in the chat from
jen which is
is the eds one sag 101 ngr complex in
the nucleus
that's another really good question um
i i think there's an active pool in the
nucleus
and that's from a number of different
studies that we've that we've done
and we we're doing some localization
studies and we think that yes there's an
interaction in the nucleus
that doesn't mean it's the only pool um
and in fact you know arabidopsis saguaro
wants nuclear
tobacco is nuclear cytoplasmic so it's
it's not an absolute
and also jeff dangles group has just
published a
bioarchive paper which claims
that nrg1 can form a autonomously former
poor
a calcium channel in fact um and that
could be the case
and i didn't have time to go into the
and that would be at the plasma membrane
um but they don't consider
the the fact that unique it means at
some stage you need
this this association or co-function
with
eds 171 for the energy want to do its
job
so i think that's something that really
needs to be understood and whether
that's
nuclear and maybe that then modifies
nig-1 in such a way that then
afterwards it can go in to the plasma
that's a
perfectly possible scenario we don't
know
one from adam other examples you know of
hybrid incompatibility arising from
mismatched
signaling components or is it all nlrs
if not that's a great question adam
there are some
um so the most the best one that comes
to mind so
most of the hybrid the immune related
hybrid incompatibility so this is
genetic mismatches when you cross
various various
accessions of paraboloxes or or even
into specific
uh crosses between plants you get this
autoimmune response
and many of them many of the causal loci
are nlrs but
um uh debt left vigo for example
identified rpw8 which is a
which is a helo domain
membrane-associated protein
um that is somehow involved in basal
immunity uh signaling uh
the components that we're interested
we've never identified those as
being causal for the um
uh h.i um and there are other
there are other components that have
been found
um certain metabolic um
dysfunctions that then are somehow
leading to an autoimmune uh
incompatibility
one from uh lean to everybody and thanks
for a wonderful talk what is the
biological relevance of eds-1 binding to
tnls does eds-1
affect the organization of the
resistosome or nuclear eds-1 tnls might
have a transcriptional regulatory
activity
yeah yeah oh yeah great question
yeah i i i we think that there's
probably a transcriptional activity
um we we identified
um eds one interacting and the es1 pad
four interacting with
with a couple of tnls in ip experiments
there was a super experiment a turbo id
experiment done by
dinesh kumar then uc davis fairly
recently where he
used tobacco n which is a tnl protein
and
he pulled out so turbo id is is where
you get this biotinylation of
associated proteins but and it's sort of
in vivo so it's before you
break up the cells and
there he identified all sorts of
interesting things
eds1 was among them so that reassured us
that yes it's probably
there um and then to your second
part is is it part of this resistor zone
i think you know if you look at the
mammalian
literature you think yeah it's it
there's got to be this concentration so
so actually that's something that we and
probably
a whole load of other people try to
identify these higher order complexes
um that may be some higher order
signaling scaffold
because you know you're bringing to get
so so that principle is you're bringing
together
these components to concentrate them to
then um act as a sort of
a kinetic downstream process
so that i wouldn't surprise me if that's
also the case in place
i think that's all which is
perfect timing thank you very much
thanks for hanging in there
it's the time to move to the next
session so thank you very much jane it
was a great seminar we really appreciate
your your willingness to visit us
virtually and
we'll continue with the schedule which
is the students and postdocs at 1 30 but
please let jane have a small break
remember
she's just being beamed around from zoom
room to zoom room and she might like to
get a drink or a quick break so
um thanks very much i'll join you i've
got a new code haven't i saw
join you in the new code room yes okay
cool thanks
thank you for a great talk
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu